ils se sont rassemblés le temps d'une
journée les maires yvelinois ont
participé ce mercredi 10 octobre à
l'université des mairies des yvelines
des communes urbaines et rurales des
diversité de situations mais une même
inquiétude au fil des ans on nous a
retiré nos compétences les jeunes après
les autres et on nous demande toujours
effectivement encore plus d'efforts avec
moins de moyens
je pense que c'est parce qu'il ya un
vrai malaise malaise par rapport au
maire et par rapport à ce que l'on vit
avec tout ce que vous savez qu'on répète
régulièrement mais aussi les charges
supplémentaires que l'on nous met sur le
dos voit les responsabilités qu'on nous
met sur le dos donc tout ça fait que eh
bien c'est nécessaire de se retrouver la
commune c'est une petite république dans
la grande
alors quand tout va mal c'est au tour du
maire et les élus municipaux que les
citoyens se retrouvent les 262
municipalités yvelinoise peuvent
s'appuyer sur le soutien d'autres
collectivités comme le département ou la
région
nous sommes nos départements déterminé
quoi qu'on veuille faire à rester le
partenaire indispensable de vos communes
et d'être toujours là pour tous vos
besoins
la région intervient notamment en
investissements pour aider les mères à
concrétiser leurs projets mais dans tous
les domaines
donc c'est très important pour moi
d'être au contact avec les maires parce
que c'est eux qui connaissent les
problèmes présents lors de cet événement
les partenaires privés gestion des
déchets de l'énergie ou encore
construction de logements la possibilité
notamment pour le maire de mort pas de
faire le point sur un chantier en cours
dans la zone paris ouest ce projet
d'écoquartier nous le nom avec kaufman
en grande partie c'est une vraie
mutation et donc ont échangé à l'instant
sur ce beau projet puisque le chantier
est en cours et il ya une autre une
autre parcelle qui va également muté
donc voilà c'est aussi de partager
l'avancée des dossiers et de s'assurer
que tout va bien
l'objectif étant pour la ville de
créer du logement social puisqu'il y
avait un déficit sur sa commune cette
commune également que pour accueillir
les nouveaux habitants sur maurepas et
propose un parcours résidentiel au mort
quasi aux jeunes roubaisiens qui avaient
des difficultés à se loger dans le parc
existant ancien des moments d'échangé de
partage les moeurs yvelinois se donnent
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition